folks joe derosa here from the taste
buds podcast
you want to see me on the road come see
me i will be in austin texas at the
creek and cave may 22 20th and 21st
that's four shows only
i'm going to be
doing more dates coming up soon
unfortunately i had to cancel my west
coast dates so i will not be performing
in irvine california or in san diego now
as i was supposed to in april but come
see me
in may at the creek and cave in austin i
promise i will make up those west coast
dates as soon as humanly possible and if
you are in the new york area come to
jelly roses at 174 rivington street
we are open tuesday through sunday get a
drink get a sandwich get both have a
good time uh if you want to know about
my show dates go to joe derosainfo.com
if you want to know about joey rose's
info you go to
joeyrosesnyc.com i hope that's not too
confusing at joderosa on instagram and
twitter
i'm talking to you directly
i'm coming on tour and i don't always do
it so you got to come see me and here we
go april 15th and 16th i will be in
louisville and evansville april 23rd and
24th i will be in tulsa and oklahoma
city beacon theater new york city first
time may 14th there's going to be some
surprise guests there and that's all i
can say but you do not want to miss that
and i'm going out west cali i'm finally
coming to you i'm going to be in san
diego on may 21st and at the wilton
theater in los angeles for the first
time ever on may 22nd everything is
available right now at savolcano
comedy.com a little bit taste buds they
coming to the mic talking about the food
they hate talking about the food they
like two fools gonna fight but only one
food can be right taste buds man yeah
they're coming to the mic i'm talking
taste buddies welcome to
t-a-s-t-e but
today's battle the fake newton versus
the fraud stripe from
keebler and the newton from the bisque
yes and we'll get into who's pick what
later and all that stuff but for now
welcome to the show yes it's a good day
good to have you rainy day bit it's a
rainy cloudy it's a cloudy day it's
cloudy waiting on a sunny day what the
hell is that a lesser-known bruce
springsteen song
waiting
bruce springsteen
oh me air guitar yeah because the last
episode isn't that a bruce springsteen
song oh thank you waiting on a sunny day
something like that on a sunny day i
don't think you're doing it maybe i'm
saying the wrong words it's down you
don't know you know the melody
wait can you can you throw it up
oh wait is it bruce springsteen oh it is
okay yeah what's it called just
a mother
the lyrics don't i didn't think it was
springsteen because the lyrics don't
sound like a uh
down-home town that he fakely came from
it does actually sound like that why you
who you think's more down home town no
cougar melon springsteen's always like
hey little girl is the barn open i gotta
come on and you're like you see where
he's from it's like jersey it's like
central jersey
that's like billy joel like every billy
joel would be like we're like me and the
boys gotta got into a fight in the park
yesterday
favorites bruce song
one of one of uh it's it's hacky i will
wear but i can't glory days glory days
gets me going i mean how could he not
picks me up yeah i mean he has so many
hits it's hard to not name a hit i like
hungry heart too hungry heart oh wait
what's hungry heart i thought of hungry
eyes when you said hungry heart which
hungry heart again dude
yeah
everybody's gotta play okay
yeah glory days
uh the promised land is an awesome song
badlands
i gotta tell you i like streets of
philadelphia
who do you guys think is a popular
artist that you hate and despise
oh
like of like my lifetime because like
now there's a lot of artists i don't
like of your lifetime of my lifetime
someone that everyone likes that i do
not like
never lie like oh i know mine good
i'm trying to think like
uh oh aerosmith
i like harrison i do not like them i
like some of it i don't like all of it i
something about it i have an adverse
reaction aerosmith i just
i don't know if i heard it too much or i
just think it's like this this category
of rock that doesn't resonate with me
it's like it's hard rock but it's not
but it's top 40 but it's not the older
stuff is better but i just hear it i'm
just like
oh aerospace every time i hear it like
it's like every time i hear a song it's
like i've heard this song a billion
times enough already
the overplayed songs are terribly
overplayed aerosmith for me is like
great he's like foo fighters where i'm
like
i could make a 20 song mix where i would
ri i would jam it i could for foo
fighters and i see who fights as the
descendants of aerosmith in a way yeah
but it's it's
but i i hear you i have no foo fighters
i'll say the two that i think
beatles rolling stones couldn't give a
[ __ ] about either of them i know but
that's but you understand that yeah
that's i couldn't the only outs that's
not that's i mean that's insane it's not
insane no i understand because aerospace
is just as popular i get it i have two
beatles right no he said a popular
artist that you don't like yeah they
were really i mean i'm saying a lot of
beatles
i am so sick of hearing people talk
about the beatles in 2022 people still
being like it's like because i'm a huge
sinatra fan and i won't even talk about
sinatra like that anymore because i'm
like nobody needs to hear it they've
heard it already i don't need to be a
person still going on and on about how
brilliant frank sinatra is and the fact
that there are still people to this day
being like well the beatles of course
man and you're like oh shut up
find a new band already jesus christ
guys
they never toured yeah what i mean
you know that you know they're they're
arguably i have two beatles records i
enjoy one and a half of two beatles
records
revolver i think is a lot of fun and
half of sergeant peppers and after that
i'm out the door all right so you got
beetles you got stones who do you stones
i can't stand
that's have you ever seen him no and i
never will i've seen him three times
excellent um
they do have more songs i don't like the
beatles have more of a like uh a hit
ratio i would say the stones have a lot
of things i don't like but some of the
stone songs are just like i would say
this about the beatles the beatles have
a concentrated type of they have two
types of music they did basically
overall for the most part they did two
genres there was the pop boys beatles
and then there was the like we met with
the shaman and sure dalai lama beatles
very much like the beastie boys yeah i
think both i think and and yeah i i
think both of those genres of the
beatles speak to a very specific type of
music
and it's either like you like that kind
of music or you don't neither of those
really gets my fancy so that's why i'm
not that into it the stones
have just simply worn out they're
welcome it's like guys
you've made way too many records
you're jumping now you've got over the
place you've got to hold on to these
guys with the for dear life you have to
i think they're still having kids aren't
they like 100 yeah they're there there
are connections to a world that is
almost completely gone we've lost
everybody in the best cameras we've lost
bowie we've
lost i think we're better off without
that world no well i mean
without bowie no not bowie specifically
but i feel like i agree with deroza
because i think the beatles were singing
to a stupider population
and then just got co-signed by is it
stupider or more
don't know it's so stupid if jupiter is
not a word i love it lemmy lemmy from
motor had talked about the comparison
that they always get compared and he's
like it's funny everybody always thinks
the the rolling stones are like the bad
boys and the beatles were kind of like
soft and he goes it's quite the opposite
it's like the beatles actually came from
like the real tough town and the stones
were actually the kind of the prissy
kids growing up
and that's that's one of the things i
really don't like about the stones i
find that the stones
figure out how to do a certain genre of
music and then do it for a little while
and sure they might be really good at it
at certain times but i just think
there's a there's a phoniness waft plus
mick jagger's a [ __ ] creep in scumbag
he you know he banged mcken he had sex
with mackenzie phillips when she was way
under age
allegedly
allegedly
no no joe it's this yeah allegedly
ready you got to do it
but now it's a no pressing ready
allegedly
that's what you say whenever you think
something's a legend all right
i like billy joel more and i like the
stones billy joel's awesome i don't
understand billy joel haters the man is
a
banger you want to talk about a 15-track
banger greatest hits bill i mean come on
dude it's awesome you know you know
people hate on billy joel you know who
who are huge who are huge
fans like of billy joel like he might be
there they're number one they've been
quoted saying the beastie boys yeah
isn't that nutty action bronson's a big
beast billy joel fan is he yeah i don't
put it back i got to interview billy
joel last year and i asked him what song
he's grown to hate and he said piano man
i gotta i got the two of us i gotta
guess that that makes everybody
as soon as i hear it i'm like oh
i hate that song i don't like scenes
from an italian restaurant i hate
captain jack i don't like that era billy
joel billy joel gets me with the
stranger
moving out if if somebody said take new
york and put it
i know but you just said you know you
said you just you just said what uh
uh
didn't you say big shot no
big shots good too though big shot's
great but i'm telling you if somebody
said what does new york sound like in
the form of a show which one attack
it's moving out yeah yeah but you're
giving it all
don't you agree with me musical around
it i love moving on i'm saying though
when you hear that song about my life
sal slow down for a second i'm just
asking a question when you hear moving
out do you also see the new york city
skyline i do it sounds like new york i
hear that song i think of arthur the
movie arthur yeah no it's not even in
the movie i just think of it no arthur
is uh christopher cross
yeah if you get caught between new york
city uh wait um which one is the one
that goes uh it's moving out right uh uh
sing moving start moving out for me
daddy and daddy
[Music]
moved on to the country no no oh yeah
oh this is a good one by the way anthony
works and see it let's see i want all my
listeners
now
if that's moving up that eye
being an adult
i still listen to the song and still at
44 years old go yeah i don't need no
stupid house out back
is that what i'm supposed to buy my
money i'm having fun and then i realized
this is a song written by a 25 year old
man
it's
no he's right
it's just so good even the next one
sergeant ali oh my god he works at mr
catchatori down on sullivan street
[Music]
who that was
a famous comedian he's talking about it
was um
don rickles no david brenner no um
super sales no can you look up who he's
talking about he's talking about um uh
who's the guy from tom hanks who's the
guy from was it belzer richard belzer it
was right but his bells are in uh yeah
richard beltzer that this would fit
belzer's timeline
i thought it was about richard beltran i
really did maybe about maybe richard
lewis
uh
oh right richard lewis it's referred us
to come on richard i thought it was
belzer oh louis i'm a big richer fan
that's awesome where'd you guys fall on
classical music he does look like a
skeleton with hair though now yes well
he's got he's got blessings no he's
having a lot of back problems he can
like barely walk i think i mean i i i
wish him the best i'm just saying he
doesn't
he's still funny he's still funny on
kirby just like i look at him like is
this an actor or is he like hobbling
around like this no no and what can we
do for him he said he could only do one
episode the last season because
he was like he's he's like oh that's sad
you know but but he's he's very positive
he's like i'm the luckiest guy in the
world yeah god bless it like he's a
great he seems like a great guy i didn't
i opened for him once
had to go at comics it went well but he
came out and i met richard belzer really
i brought
this is really cool i brought
richard
uh what was this i brought richard
belzer on stage to introduce richard
lewis
and then when i walked off stage i met
richard belzer for the first time i met
him on stage for the first time and then
i walked off and then he walked off and
richard bells are saying like good set
me you're funny like it was just cool
man it was like that was one of those
moments you remember and i remember i
met larry miller at comics i'm a big fan
of
and i didn't go on he tells a hell of a
joke yeah i love larry miller i didn't
go on but i met him backstage and i go
man i'm such a big fan i'm a comic voila
and i go you're so funny and he goes he
goes thank you and he goes that means
extra special that's extra special
coming from one of the one of my
brothers
because
i was like and i was like and i laughed
and goes i'm serious and i was like wow
you really like appreciate stand up yeah
you know i wish i could have been in
that era
i know i wish i could have been in that
era man it was such a different era i
think you guys would have dominated the
catskills era
[Laughter]
i'll take any of that error i know i i
yeah that was f oh classical music no
pimp i i i appreciate it i don't listen
to it classical i respect what do you
think mozart's a genius or an [ __ ] i
think he's probably why would he be both
he's probably do you ever see immortal
that's beethoven immortal beloved
amadeus guy's brutal amadeus is that's
mozart right yeah i would say both dicks
amadeus is more of a fun dick beethoven
was like a real son of a [ __ ] yeah but
they're both geniuses but i mean i i
don't listen to it but i respect him i
[ __ ] with bach though
yeah i [ __ ] with bach
why not
that should be a t-shirt i [ __ ] with
bach though uh i listen to it
i know that i should make me sound like
that is good right
though yeah yeah that's a good that's a
good shirt i will tell you i know this
will make me sound like
an old an old man but from when i was
younger i don't listen to uh terrestrial
radio at all and if i listen to
something in the car i told you it's one
of three things it's either stern
or it's it's either classical music or
just jazz that's all i listen to in the
car unless i'm plugging my own like
playlist off of spotify which is really
not not an often have you seen this kid
out there that's doing the stern
impression now i mean he does
impressions all over he's all over
youtube
dude it's the greatest i don't know if
i've ever seen how it's during
impression dude this kid hold on scroll
down pimp
this podcast is sponsored by better help
people
don't always realize that physical
symptoms like headaches teeth grinding
sort of things check digestive issues
check are indicators of stress check
let's not forget about doom scrolling
checks oh yeah sleeping too little
chicken too much underrating chick uh uh
overeating under eating under and i i
did say underrating and i'm gonna stay
there under aiding and overrating is
also to me a symptom of stress when
you're going to extremes with everything
stress shows up in many forms right the
point it's a silent killer and then it's
also a vocal killer for example joe
derosa is stress okay
and the world's telling you to do more
about about about what's going on to you
and i i experience stress who is there a
person on this on god's green that
doesn't experience stress every single
day
yeah i get stressed
you seem cool as a cucumber do less do
less okay take care of yourself and and
just relax and try some therapy people
okay just try it better help is is is is
with an online therapist in under 48
hours it's customized online therapy it
offers video phone and even live chat
sessions with the therapist so you don't
have to see anyone on camera if you
don't even want to much more affordable
than in-person therapy i can attest to
that give it a try and see if online
therapy can help lower your stress this
podcast is sponsored by better help and
taste buds listeners will get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
tastebuds that's
uh we love bespoke post here uh
people say two bespoke poses it is
actually it does roll off the tongue
bespoke post is kind of uh
this winter upgrade your daily routine
with bespoke posts and a new seasonal
lineup of a must-have box of awesome
collections so what they do is they
partner with small businesses and
and brands to bring you unique goods
every month and they choose them or you
could talk about kind of you know you
could be surprised or you can whittle it
down to like what you like and what you
want to see more of no matter what
you're into they have you covered it's
things from winter cocktails to cozy
threads to camping gear essentials every
part of your life uh and i actually i
told you this last time i ordered it i
would normally do this but i ordered a
machete and i'm proud to have that in my
house right now you get started by
taking i also ordered a um uh uh what do
you call those uh when you carry a suit
in it the bag where you carry yourself
yeah garment bag a garment bag yeah yeah
yeah there you go yeah what's that
called the bag you put your garments in
yeah
anyway you get started by taking quiz at
box of awesome.com your answers will
help them pick the right box of awesome
for you
they release new boxes every month
across a ton of different categories
it's free to sign up you can skip a
month or cancel at any time each box
costs 45 bucks but has
dollars over seventy dollars worth of
that's where the value comes in yeah
plush
plush plus what am i what am i talking
about here a stuffed animal plus with
each box of awesome you're supporting
small business that's true ninety
percent of everything that comes in your
box of awesome is from a small
up-and-coming brand you get 20
off your first monthly box when you sign
up at box of awesome.com and enter the
code tastebuds at checkout that's box of
awesome.com code tastebuds for 20
off your first box
you want to go see billy joel at the
garden again have you seen him yes i
want to go i think that's back up and
running i've seen it twice over the last
five years or whatever yes it's always
an
insane fun sing-along we should all go
have you guys you guys know billy joel
it's that [ __ ] have you seen his show at
the garden do you know his music i
interviewed him once
i don't know his music at all what else
did you ask him why did you why did you
interview him by the way jazz and chaz
ran out of questions
that's so funny that that happened
i gotta find this kid the impression is
insane
are you on youtube yeah i think just
just old stearns clips are coming to the
top
uh howard stern impression
we'll look around put actually oh yeah
that's right his
uh uh uh
his name is
his name is up his handle is a play on
saturday night live what maybe
impression of howard stern
best impression of howard stern
dude it's so good like he does tons of
people and he's excellent at all of them
but his stern literally i'm like i
couldn't tell the difference if that was
actually how it started or not matter
that's him matter day night live this is
him this this impression is insane dude
pain in the ass right it doesn't fit
around my face that's not him nightmare
that's him doing a tick-tock no it's the
kid doing the impress
that's not how he's turned his voice no
i'm telling you i literally couldn't
like if i closed my eyes i'm sure he's
not doing it
i've seen him do it in a million videos
his impressions are nuts
right so i've got this face mask and
it's such a pain in the ass right it
doesn't fit around my face it's a total
nightmare okay
what's going what the hell is going on
it doesn't work
wow
if i had my eyes closed i have turned it
up a little
his impressions look here he is doing it
to bobby moynihan you meditate john
i do i do as much as i can right same i
love it too
that's oh serious howard i like sirius
right too right well siriusxm man
[Laughter]
wow
that is the name of your that is the
name of the radio station
once again
it's i think someone is doing some yard
work near you is or is that is that do
you have a window
yeah isn't it something there's one
you're born with that yeah
you can't you can't learn that you can't
learn that
one of my favorites again and we were
talking about how nobody does a good
impression even on snl nobody's been
able to do it but there's this one
who's 23 years old he doesn't impress me
on take time whatever you want to call
it
i think it's okay i mean i i don't think
it sounds much like
that is i've never heard anyone do that
he does he does like gold bloom he does
so many that's that's i wish i could do
that i wish i could do that can we hire
him to read your dates that would be
amazing oh my god he does liv shriver to
liv shriver look look at this
hi everybody this
is the great
[Music]
he's great he's so good dude he'll be on
snl
his thing is matter day night live like
because he clearly that's like his dream
he'll be on it he's got to be how do you
know crazy dude
anyway well good for him shout out
all right she's up to 48 thousand dude
that shot i think that's just a friend
because when i first looked him up i was
like this i bet you're a tick-tock he's
huge he's got to be right
anyway he's great i want to meet him
he's at caroline's let's go see him
do you know you know what you're someone
that you can do an impression of
yeah you are yeah you have attributes
where i think someone could lock into
them
i would love to see it i don't know i'd
be honored don't know if he wasn't used
to an impression of me really yeah i
don't know if i uh if anyone's ever done
an impression of me that would be wild i
think you got an impressionable thing
going on you think i do yeah yeah listen
let's get into the battle yeah all right
geez all right
two powerhouses again where are we at
time-wise pimp yeah all right ready as
you guys know there's a new chant it's
an adversarial chant now
i think we should shorten the response
time to 15 seconds 30 was going on
forever
oh it was a minute all right cut it to
30 seconds i wanted some blood yeah i
wasn't even done
all right i got upset with you guys do
you want to do the insole first okay
i don't give a [ __ ]
sure yeah whatever you want are you
ready you do first
okay yeah all right ready yeah it's time
to get salty it's time to get salty it's
time to get salty enough with the staten
island already it's stupid oh my
goodness stupid
nobody cares
you're insulting everything about me
yeah nobody wants to drive out here
anymore we get it you grew up here
nobody cares nobody cares move away to
where people live enough already enough
it's ridiculous it's ridiculous am i out
to speak
[Laughter]
who's the brain dead [ __ ] that put that
tattoo on you
and is he more brained brain-dead are
you more brain-dead than him for paying
for that all they did was color your arm
black there's no art there whatsoever if
you look at the comments for the last 65
episodes every week somebody wants to
know what the [ __ ] happened to your
forearm you don't like this
all right here we go here we go
that's permanent
all right ready dude this the insult is
so funny
it's shocking and then before we could
say a word back you you're blasting
pants
and you're so funny looking at them just
smiling hitting them
and it's like so official like oh the
boss and pants you can't sing anymore
all right
time to p-a-t-t-l-e
today's battle keebler's uh fudge
striped cookies versus nabisco's fig
newtons i am team fig newton sal is come
on now fudge stripe like an
80 i i can't look i've been losing a lot
lately i'm aware of that i don't care
because uh because taste is in the is in
the palate of the gods
and you don't ever
you don't ever want to be in the
majority vote majority vote is always
the wrong side of
history that's so nice nice speaking of
rewriting this that's a nice way to put
it yeah so i don't care that i'm going
to lose it but i got to say this right
now i can't believe i can't believe this
you're putting your fudge i can't
believe you're putting them
up against
fig newton is the definition of nature
buddy think newton's stripe is literally
top 102 products for keebler as a whole
here's what you're here's what you're
mistaking right now keebler does
a lot of fudge based cookies they like
to do they do the el fudge do the fudge
stripe i'm sure there are others
they do there's like at least three or
four other ones their thing is is that
we do we do cookies that bring in that
bring fudge into the mix you know a lot
of the time blah blah blah
fig newton is the brand fig newton is
the oreo you know what i'm saying dude
i'm telling you right now that arguably
is not even it's not even arguably not
even point is is fig newton is the
umbrella thing that then they vary the
newton under it they don't fudge stripes
they don't put that out and then vary it
underneath oh you're going to have no
argument today that's your what you're
leading with i'll leading it with it
first of all i will i will tell you that
right now i think the the fudge stripe
by keebler is for me
is a top three all-time cookie okay oreo
is first
and then i honestly believe possibly
fudge stripe is second and d you're the
one who told me that you've never had a
french tribe who's never had a fudge
shrimps many times
you could eat a package there are only
four rows and they're about seven or
eight across and they go great with milk
i mean i can't remember the last time
but the chocolate carrot the chocolate
keeps them together so they don't break
apart into the milk when you dunk
because the chocolate forms the base
that you need and the cookie part can be
soft and when you bite into it there's
still a snap from the chocolate they're
not overwhelming they're thin so you can
eat a few of them and not feel like
you're going downhill they've been
consistent since i'm a little kid okay
keebler's is slept on
listen i'm on the whole keyboard
strip where the older i got the less i
was in the fudge stripes the the coconut
aspect of it
started to lose me after a while and i
don't know if it has coconut in it or if
it just tastes like coconut there's no
coconut in there there's definitely a
coconut it's a gram it's a it's a butter
cookie it's a graham cracker cookie with
a fudge stripe and now they're getting
into all sorts of fun new stuff which i
haven't eaten adventure there's a bit of
a coconutty flavor to the fudge stripe
in my opinion
there i don't know what it is but
there's something it doesn't matter
that's neither here nor there dude do
you want to talk about it i was even
aware chocolate fudge with strawberry
french fries pumpkin spice with with
cream cheese look that's got that's got
a coconut on it scroll up to that
picture up no no
that's a girl scout cookie right oh oh
that's what i'm thinking of okay
oh it is oh really
so what
so samoas came from keebler
where they ripped off oh they have it
also has pecan sandys oh god so good
and they got their chips whoops fred
stripes
dunked in fudge look here's the thing i
don't even need to bring another flavor
of fudge stripe into this fudge stripe
is such a powerhouse it stands alone on
its own i love it i'm surprised that you
brought in a fig newton first off when i
was a little kid
how much do you want to talk for by the
way before i can't say anything it's a
podcast i'm i mean what i'm saying let
me
stop let me count a point you want to
talk about not feeling like you're going
down only a stupid [ __ ] like you
would say you can eat three fudge based
cookies and not feel like you're you're
eating something bad they're pure
chocolate salad you want to talk about
eating something not feeling bad fig
newton it's got fruit filling in it
things are good for you
big newtons are terrible pull up their
their
until the late 19th century many
physicians believed that most illnesses
were related to digestion problems and
recommended a daily intake of biscuits
and fruit fig rolls were the ideal
solution to this advice so you're
speaking against yourself right now i
don't know what this is oh let's just
say big newton's wikipedia page
first of all first of all figs prunes
they're good for you they're good for
your digestion oh look at that
goddamn prune cookie it's so soft when i
was little
i'm saying
i think i'm battling you i think i'm
battling a cookie versus what is a
newton let's go to this let's go i want
to tell you something
by the way by the way this this jerk-off
i had to tell him it was fudge stripes
he thought that these cookies were
called el fuzz oh i didn't momentarily
oh my god you're nuts you're out of your
mouth i know what the fudge is it's it's
the literally it's like an oreo with the
character of the keebler elf no fudge in
the middle but two sides of it
because i told you whatever that's what
i could discuss newton's third most
popular cookie in the u.s over a billion
consumers well i will tell you right now
i had no idea that's that really i'm a
little nervous now what are the first
two fip give me the top ten cookies each
year in the u.s let's go top ten i can't
believe you know why oh that's the only
cookie an old person eating let's see
it's a senior citizen they're not an
older person that is chocolate chip
cookie the nursing home cookie fake
newton the official cookie of the
nursing home and i asked you again what
is a newton black i
is there anything besides a fig newton
is there something else new there's an
apple newton those are wonderful do you
remember strawberry newton's strawberry
newton
cook top ten cookie brands we should say
pimp because this is going to give us
types of cookies
excuse me
hold on let's see most cookie brand us
top ten that's not gonna
there you go 35 most popular cookie
brands in america let's start at number
one
oh
yeah
make your bed
now lay down according to the other
thing the word number three all right
number one oreo no no surprise there no
surprise number two the oh that's a that
should be in a battle my friend that's
ridiculous the milano
you got the balls to talk to me about
what old people eat and you want to
bring pepperidge farms cookies into this
mexican right now are you pepperdrome's
not
is the third most sold cookie in this
country that's asinine it didn't say
souls it didn't say sold popular there
you go a keyboard coconut dream is what
you're thinking of and that is basically
going to be
a three i got mixed up for a second i
know what the fact that i love famous
amos actually
double stuff there's no way that
brussels is number seven dude we're not
even seeing that
vienna there's also this is crazy that's
a that's a bad list i think that was
someone's favorite cookies that's the
bisco oreo nabisco by the way who make
mine cookies too by the way we are
precious [ __ ] oreos they also make
the fig newton you know what i think of
fig newton i think of an old person this
is when i was little i'm telling you
right now if we pull
people 15 and under they have not had a
fig newton i think 15 and under in this
day and age sure no way dude no way it
it's it it's it's it's no i'm saying it
has a reputation
don't know who bob dylan is what the
hell does that mean 20 and under people
don't eat fig newtons until they're old
okay
you know about a cookie that is that is
not a cookie dough
aiding digestion sal it's just not true
it is it's not true nobody wants there
are so many different fake newton
flavors
it's good
hit me with the talk about flavor though
right
delicious the fingernail is just a big
cookie it's a delicious cookie fig
newton flavors
[ __ ]
fruit filling in the middle of us
apple cinnamon you ever have the apple
cinnamon fake newton it's unreal
dude you're arguing
you're arguing fig newtons you're not
arguing strawberry noons raspberry
noodles well you keep bitching about the
newton aspect of it the new aspect of it
is the best part
it's a soft cake i don't know what to
tell you
what is a freaking nabisco elf what are
you tara keebler ralph you're talking
about a cake you got elves making a
keyboard keebler is the brand and alpha
is a magical creature what are you
talking about what is a newton i asked
you again putting what is it newton
what is this what is it
was described as clear-headed
oh my god keebler actually started in a
bakery in philadelphia right where
you're from
he took on various businesses okay
godfrey keebler
is where key laurels comes from he is
the creator of the first keebler cookie
in 1853
in his small neighborhood shop
okay
yeah
that's great incorporated in 1890 three
years from his death and his bakery
became part of the united business
company what the hell is this 1926
cookie there are 16 killer bakeries
across the country in 1944 okay so first
elf appeared in i'm giving i'm sorry i'm
doing the background of keeping so what
you're you're saying pointless [ __ ] who
cares
we always give a background of the
product give a background to the cookie
not the company the first elf appeared
in 1969 okay fine yeah then came ernie
you want to read that part there's a
whole lot of the questions
let's talk about who animated the
cartoons i didn't know what you're
talking about oh my god keebler bakeries
produce girl scout cookies oh great girl
scouts the goddamn girl scouts yes thank
you so samoa thank you ripped off
keebler samoa the girl scouts go all
over the world and i said it once and
i'll say it again
and they're based on [ __ ] no they're not
don't talk about those girls like that
yes yeah oh baby
electric e-bikes yes i got mine i got
mine too i got mine i wrote this thing
all over me talking about today
yesterday oh my god
ronnie i used to ride a regular bike
around manhattan years ago i had one and
i enjoyed it but there are limitations
one of the biggest problems i had with
riding a bike in manhattan was this
you you are forced to integrate in and
out of traffic yeah you can't stay in a
bike lane all the time sometimes you
have to integrate with traffic and that
can be a little frightening or
intimidating when you're on a regular
bike if you're not a regular cyclist
because you have to
sort of pick up the pace yeah and then
slow it down and whatever
an electric bike electric bike
you need that little boost you got that
throttle there you also have assisted
pedaling so when you're halfway through
the journey if you overdo it you can put
on the pedals you can choose which one
you want to do exactly look if you're a
city dweller or you live on a country
road it's going to be fun either way
save on gas leave the car at home help
the planet out uh they start at just
7.99 they're the fastest growing e-bike
company united states they're affordable
customizable they ship free and fully
assembled i like that you can fold them
in half for storage so you don't need a
bike rack you don't need to throw them
in a truck to bring them somewhere so
it's great their mission is simple make
e-bikes accessible for everyone finally
that's happening yeah surprisingly
affordable i told you 7.99 uh what else
the batteries are in the way you would
tell me
it's helping to cut down on emissions
and saving you money on gas uh it's a
durable and convenient design as you
already said the battery is great you're
getting uh let's see i think up to 45
miles at up to 28 miles per hour on just
one four to six hour chart that's wild
that's great way more eco-friendly than
a car explore the great outdoors or the
city while keeping the air clean and
what i really really like about this is
there is a walk assist mode on it
so if you have to walk the bike and
you're pooped
you can actually there's a thing where
you're not rushing the motor and that's
so funny with it uh and i also like too
that like especially when you're first
getting into biking and you don't know
what your limits are you can really push
yourself on this thing and then when you
hit that turnaround point and you're
you're dosed right
closed home basically throttle right
right just cruise my last e-bike my last
e-bike that i bought was i'm not joking
it was almost four times more expensive
than this and it did not have this one
has an lcd like reader that'll tell you
your battery how fast you're going
everything like that
yeah it's awesome join the affordable
ebike revolution go to electric
ebikes.com and use code taste buds to
get a free foldable
mountable bike lock with any bike
purchase that's cool that's a free bike
lock when you use taste buds use code
taste buds at l e c
t r i c
e
b i k e s that's electric
ebikes.com
joey spring is around the corner and
people are opening their yards up i just
told you i want to open up my patio
again and the number one thing we need
to look into is we need to take care of
our lawns and that's why we're talking
about sunday now i don't have a lawn
because i live in manhattan but if i did
you yell for kids to get off my hair but
my dad has
my dad and my mom have a lawn and i
would like to get them in touch with
this product i think well thankfully
sunday uh get your lawn growing and
helps to keep uh fresh and healthy all
season long uh don't worry about all the
chemicals you're used to uh keeping to
make your yard look best traditional
lawn care lays down 90 million pounds of
pesticides a year so sunday does it
differently they're on a mission to
change how people care for their yards
uh you don't have to choose between
having a beautiful yard and keeping your
family out of harm's way most of us
might think about our lawns in the
winter but this is the time to prep for
this year you're probably thinking you
have so much work to do to get it green
and healthy again but sunday takes all
the work out for you yes custom plans
include fertilizer and everything you
need to easily care for your lawn with
ingredients like seaweed and iron and
molasses instead of nasty chemicals
that's very nice giving you a beautiful
lawn all you got to do is visit
sunday.com put in your address and their
lawn analysis tool does the rest
sunday can help you grow a beautiful
lawn without the guesswork or the nasty
chemicals i said the nasty chemicals
well i mean it was highlighted and you
didn't read that part we ad-lib some but
some they want us to say and i want to
make sure i hit it for the people i got
a little creative i'm sorry well
sometimes you get creative and we always
like the people at sunday that have now
created this wonderful business you get
creative sometimes
we're the people who pay when you get
creative anyway sunday is offering
listeners 20 off full season plans start
at just 129. you can get 20 off at
checkout when you visit
getsunday.com tastebuds 20 2-0 that's
getsunday.com
two zero to get twenty percent off your
custom plan at get sunday dot com slash
tastebuds two zero i love it and i also
wanna say one thing there's this pouch
that you attach to your hose and then
you run everything through the hose and
you water for 15 minutes and you're done
so it's not about laying something
that's my favorite part of it that's
very cool yeah actually all right all
right i mean we've sold this thing we
sold it let's go get sunday.com
tastebuds 2-0
okay they go around and clean this samoa
as their own meal meanwhile the samoa
product that'd be like saying this
shitty comedian stole from uh uh
what was the guy that had the show that
stole her way to fizzle out carlos
mencia this shitty comic stole from
carlos francie oh big surprise the [ __ ]
bag stole from [ __ ] wait go back to that
go back two two two right
hold on
the kennedy biscuit company had recently
oh okay you want so can you just type in
what is a goddamn newton please don't
write goddamn what is the newton we'll
screw it up does that something to do
with massachusetts what has it got to do
with
massachusetts the product was named
after the city of new york okay stupid
[ __ ]
you stupid
that there was [ __ ]
newton massachusetts yeah who knew that
there you go there you go
all right there you go
well it's from philly that's what my
thing is i don't give a [ __ ] where he's
from you can't get in
philadelphia
please oh wait a second go back to that
look at that
the kennedy biscuit company and the new
york biscuit company
merged to form nabisco after which the
fig girls were trademarked as fig
newtons okay i'll tell you nothing i
don't think it's a cookie number number
one number two cookie show dude you when
you bite into that you it it isn't
acquired a fig newton is an acquired
taste nobody's liking chunks of process
what does that have to do with it not
with it not being a cookie what are you
talking about it's a cake product it's a
cookie it's a cakey product for fruit
it's big newton's a cookie great to eat
but cookie or cake fig newtons won't
tell you oh they won't even tell you
themselves but you sitting on my couch
here today yeah on all the day of our
lives
here's the thing it's an amazing product
that remains mysterious your product is
so dumb and made for dumb [ __ ] they had
to put elves on the package
just double back on what you said and
you said it's a goddamn cookie and then
you said it's it's the remains of your
argument ready
i don't give a [ __ ] what it is it's
better than what yours is yeah how about
that i think newton is for people with
dentures that's what a fig newton is
where are you getting this that's what
it is when i was little they were for
old people nobody touched a fig newton
it tasted like prunes and figs and it
was disgusting it's it's like a pop-tart
consistency as a pop-tart
google the nutrition facts because
you're going to be wow yeah i'm sure
you're just chubby wow i'm sure your all
chocolate cookie is better for you
around google google nutrition factors
i'm sure they're only using the finest
chocolate i think they have two
factories where they print the fudge
stripes [ __ ] [ __ ] i think i think a
fig newton has like two big news like
150 calories i'm not kidding all right
let's see this is for you joe here quick
this is a thanks to the abundance of
figs in each bar which is known to be
one of the highest plant sources of both
calcium and fiber each serving is also
full of copper manganese magnesium
potassium calcium vitamin k and
antioxidants there's even protein in
them you lose you lose you were reading
the thing for the organic nature's way i
read what i read and i'm going to apply
it to my cookies
[Laughter]
let's series in one fig newton
55 all right
55 calories and one fig newton okay
calories in one fudge stripe
that's not one though 70. yes it is no
it sounds like it is
140. there you go fat ass
i don't think that's right
that's what do you mean you don't think
that's right i don't think that's right
that's right i don't think it's right
why is it not right go to the go to a
reputable source
oh my god you're just such it's just
such i love that the internet's never
right when it applies to you
it's so crazy it just doesn't sound
right pimp i got
here's here's how to solve it go to the
goddamn keebler website all right i see
it okay there you go right there you go
140 calories
two cookies let's just do just as just
let's just talk taste let's talk taste
i'll talk to you i'm eating a cookie i
want chocolate i want butter i want
carrots what do you want okay i don't
want i don't want i don't want a mushy
flavor it's not mushy it's a wonderful
soft experience with a great fruit
filling
for people with incontinence figs in the
right in the right situation figs are
amazing
they're an amazing flavor in the right
situation yeah
i mean i wouldn't eat figs out of a bag
i'm not into it but i'll tell you what i
make i make a cheese and and super salt
platter i got a little fig spread on
there are you crazy it's it's
unbelievable i like it there it takes it
to the next level dude did you know
about the newton family now i will tell
you something the newton fruit thins are
one of my favorite cookies you but you
son of a [ __ ]
joe you want why are you being why are
you being such a terrible person right
now that is not it's not a fake newton
whatsoever it doesn't have fig in it
they're newton's
newton's fruit thins it's complete
that's a blueberry on the end there
is a cherry which flavor do you get when
you get it blueberry 100 cherry as a
matter of fact i thought these were
discontinued
because they came out of nowhere they
came into my life out of nowhere
seven eight years ago and i was raving
about them they shot to the top of my
mind there's a better version of your
cookie
dark fudge banana that's banana no it's
banana and dark fudge as i said it's a
better version of your that that has
nothing to do with your argument at all
i just said there's a better version of
your comments
are your little elves pumping out
newton's because they're not newton
fructans newton fruitins have nothing to
do with fig newtons it's a completely
different cookie line completely made a
different way is a hard biscuit cookie
circular
that is made from gram and they put
fruit into it that is dried it's not the
same exact thing there's little fruit
bits in it it's not a fake new and a
fake newton looks like a fig sandwich a
little fig sandwich i'll tell you why
else the newton is better you can't eat
a fudge striped cookie without
disgusting hands afterwards you can't do
it the entire bottom is a melting fudge
uh coating how long are you holding
these things in your hand
what do you [ __ ] tell them about
if i'm like you i walk around shuffling
them in my hand for a while before i eat
them
so but my point is is fig newton's not
messy they're all it's not messy it's
it's cakey sushi right into it comes
into it yeah that's going in my
footstripe will have a snap
i forgot you just one throat them yeah
well that's right yeah keebler let's go
to the phones keebler fudge stripes are
gross fig newton's for the win i hope
joe picked figgy scroll up right there i
hope joe picked figgy newts so he can
revive the no teeth required argument
i've been eating those since i was born
jack thank you yes again i told you
again it's a people with dentures
against your argument since i was born
it's not always because you have no
teeth there as well i said it's for
people with no teeth it's for people of
all ages that's a different i wanted a
fake newton i'd eat a nutrigreen bar
it's the same [ __ ] let me tell you
what you asked me a moment ago why i'm
being such a bad person
remember
bees have sex on facebook remember bees
have sex you remember when you just
asked me that bees have sex on facebook
okay do you remember when you especially
was being said
do you remember when you asked me why i
was being such a bad person yeah it's
because you were getting a little
generally awesome this is the exact kind
of argument and i can smell it in the
air i'm gonna go downstairs he's gonna
have fig newtons in his cabinet no i
don't buy them feel it i don't feel like
it'll not purchase i've never purchased
fig newtons i've never purchased them
you've been in my home a million times
have you ever seen a newton anywhere i
haven't seen a lot of things i could
either
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
can i celebrate the man please we rarely
do this we will keep reading some
comments i think we need to give the win
to bruce with that because that is so
funny and then also i love that his
handle is bruce on the rocks which is
making me laugh for some reason
i love it can we go down hello at bruce
on the rocks for the winning tweet but
we're still going to read more i love
you now the next right below it okay we
didn't look at the phone still now
fans are spinning in their urns
let's give another win
underscore evan oh that's amazing fig
newtons are for old people hoping it
will help them take a [ __ ]
all right look i'm not saying there's no
truth today big news
is cookie plain and simple fig noons are
the cookies you find at the great aunt
haunted house why is this even an
argument fudge stripes all day any
person who eats fig newtons are two
seconds from the nursing home
oh my god everything i said is the only
thing that's being posted
see i'm in an echo chamber in here you
know what's interesting i'm seeing a lot
of fans say they use the fudge stripes
to make s'mores
oh wow
that is that is
very interesting honestly i'm 27 and i
never had a fudge stripe in my life and
i don't care to try them
at least he was honest big nudes are one
of the worst snacks of all time straight
garbage fig disgusting
uh fudge stripes are good but there's a
million cookies like them they're just
good or are just as good or better it's
fruit and cake see it's not even they
won't even tell you it's a cookie
shout outs
fig newtons are for the elders newton's
float my boat but i'm sure joe derosa
comedy will pick the wait we'll pick the
newton so that is my choice thank you
simply granny it's about time somebody's
oh this is going to be a and this is
going to be
this is going to be wild you want to
stop placing bets now if it's the
biggest win of all time
the boomers be like yum fig newtons
anyone chooses fake news as a senior
citizen who can only mash the fig dudes
with their guns
by the way i i mean where's all the
ageism coming from since why is it bad
for an old person to have a food they
can eat you know all of you are gonna
get old yeah exactly
exactly i got no problem i have no
problem getting old all i'm just saying
is that like
fake news is known as like a nursing
home cookie fudge stripes sound like
tighty whities
[Laughter]
make newtons sound like a philosopher
that's very funny
why would you even ask senora velcano we
all know the answer
to quote the buds no one ever said i
love figs what psycho wouldn't pick a
crispy chocolate treat
they're not crispy by the way
are you insane they used to be crispy no
no but now they're
chewing no they're not chewy no they're
not chewy
i mean now you're just lying on the
stand you're lying they're crispy
they're actually they would never not
crispy fudge stretch is what they call
christie's underwear
if you voted fig newtons i hate you that
makes two of us sunshine lemons all
right let's let's go to the let's get
the vote this should not be a question
let's get the vote
i mean you're right you're insane let's
all right we're at ten thousand hold on
we're at ten thousand votes ten thousand
one hundred and twelve votes are we at
what we have time yeah right now drum
roll pimpy here we go
oh my god oh my god
81.7
fudge stripes to
18.3 fig newton oh you old [ __ ] just go
in the corner
go in the corner and just hide your face
and shove fig newtons in them and help
them make you digest later just put on
an adult diaper go in the corner and
just feast on your newtons
you stupid [ __ ] just
you probably store newtons in your
tighty whities
you gonna say the line dumbass head in
the show
[Laughter]
come see me at the beacon didn't make
this hotel the beacon theater may 14th
new york city county county.com i still
love you
babe talking about the food they hate
talking about the food they like two
fools gonna fight but only one food can
be right taste buds man yeah they're
coming to the mic i'm talking taste buds
cheers